welcome to Hannity tonight we're
tracking multiple breaking stories all
across the country at this hour polls
have closed in several states will call
races throughout the hour as they
results very tight race Kentucky
governor going on as we speak
plus we are following a horrific story
out of northern Mexico where earlier
today well at least nine Americans were
murdered including six children during
an apparent ambush by a Mexican cartel
coming up we'll have the latest
developments also tonight
why did ABC cover up a major story
surrounded convicted pedophile Jeffrey
Epstein Bill Clinton and Prince Andrew
in 2015 a bombshell new video uncovered
by James O'Keefe and Project Veritas
reveals one reporter struggle to get her
own network to cover this inconvenient
truth take a look I've had the story for
three years I've had this interview with
Virginia Roberts we would not put it on
the air first of all I was told who's
Jeffrey Epstein no one knows who that is
this is a stupid story then the palace
found out that we had her whole
allegations about Prince Andrew and
threatened us a million different ways
we were so afraid we wouldn't be able to
interview Kate
we'll think that we also quashed the
story we'll show you the entire shocking
damning video coming up two moments away
first big breaking news thanks to
investigative reporter tonight John
Sullivan we now have our hands on yet
another document revealing a shocking
level of coordination between the Obama
State Department Joe Biden and hunter
Biden's very lucrative position with no
experience at all
a Purisima holdings in Ukraine now
compliments of Solomon and a Freedom of
Information Act request newly obtained
memos from June of 2016 show the State
Department officials they actually
prepped the new US ambassador to Ukraine
on how to handle questions about
Purisima holdings and yeah the millions
they're paying no experienced hunter
Biden imagine if Donald Trump did this
imagine that and if you're wondering by
the way this is the same ambassador to
Ukraine who recently apparently
testified that I had some role in the
allegations that led to her resignation
in reality despite the obsessive fake
news reporting by the media mob I don't
know anything about this woman her name
was barely mentioned but a few times on
this program just in passing basically
and to this day I haven't talked to
anyone from Ukraine that I knew was from
Ukraine nobody ever I certainly wasn't
words not lobbying for her removal but
that did not stop the mass hysteria from
the mob over yours truly I think they
like putting my face on TV because then
they can trick viewers that would never
would watch them thinking it's Fox I
don't know take a look in the new
transcript out tonight this ambassador
details how sean hannity's attacks on
her and his alleged support of aspects
of the ukraine claude made it to the
highest levels of the State Department
the Secretary of State says that he will
call sean hannity to try to find out
what the deal is with this whisper
campaign of slander that is being
directed at her to get her removed the
fact that at one point in time secretary
Pompeo said he had to call sean hannity
to find out what US foreign policy was
in one of these transcripts so I mean
the level of insanity and craziness and
venality is just unmatched she basically
is saying he got a state media is out to
get you right now that's what that is
that's the that's that's the that's the
you know what would happen with tasks
you know in the Soviet Union in 1974
it's like state media's turned against
you the only way to get the guys in
state media to back off is to offer a
sacrifice to the gods he really is a
dumb jackass just for the record by the
way
I never talked to the Secretary of State
or anybody else from the State
Department all of what you saw Oh
shouldn't be surprised surprising let's
see a hoax
more fake news more conspiracy theories
none of that happened by the way mr.
sucker I hope your stenographer Humpty
Dumpty is taking notes but back to
solomon's big breaking news now found in
the newly uncovered documents oh and by
the way this is real news in 2016 a
sample question and answers section
actually is prepping this ambassador
person I don't know who and what
about how to answer questions during
your Senate confirmation hearing one
unredacted section reads quote question
do you have any comment on hunter Biden
the vice president's son serving on the
board of ERISA a major Ukrainian gas
company and they suggest the answer for
questions on hunter Biden's role in
Purisima I would refer you to the Vice
President Joe Biden's office
remember Biden has been vehemently
denying ever talking to his son about
his Ukrainian business deals but in June
of 2016
yep sleepy Joe creepy Joe Biden was the
official point person for all matters
related to hunter Biden and Maurice
Mahal dings so another flat-out lied
which even contradicts his own son by
the way who said in an interview in The
New Yorker yeah we did talk about it and
by the way Biden said he and hunter did
nothing wrong nothing will correct this
in a second but take a look no one's
established that he did anything wrong
or that I've done anything wrong period
I carried out the policy of the United
States of America our allies the
International Monetary Fund the EU and
dealing with a corrupt prosecutor period
number one I did not know he was on the
board of that company and in fact no
one's asserted on the board that was
illegal from there the board he did
anything wrong and if you had known
would you have said don't or would you
believe he said this is wrong no it's
not wrong he his words speak for
themselves he wish he had realized how
thugs like Rudy Giuliani and his cronies
and the cronies of the president would
try to paint it nothing wrong no
experience Ukraine gas oil energy
millions of dollars no nothing wrong no
money no experience China private
equities that we can see Oh looks like
Joe 303 three one'd some help with some
pretty basic fundamental facts and this
is where the mob and the media is
exposed as so corrupt so I won't might
want to remind sleepy creepy crazy Uncle
Joe that his son Hunter it wasn't
selling his experience he had zero
experience
an oil gas energy or Ukraine none but he
did have a direct line to his father who
was the vice president of the United
States the second highest elected man in
the United States in charge of yes
policy in Ukraine the only reason hunter
Biden was getting paid millions of
dollars with zero experience for his
so-called services they wanted favor
from the Biden's as it turns out we can
report tonight it looks like a pretty
good investment for verissimo Holdings
why because in February 2016 3 weeks
after Ukrainian Ukrainian authorities
conducted a search warrant at the home
of hunter Biden's boss at Purisima
Holdings all representative for the
company was actively communicating with
the Obama State Department according to
another newly unearthed email courtesy
of John Solomon and his Freedom of
Information Act request the barrese me
rep was lobbying the Obama
administration to end all corruption
allegations against the company
arguing quote even two high-profile US
citizens are affiliated with the company
including hunter Biden as a board member
oh that's why they paid mr. zero
experience hunter Biden millions of
dollars and then one month later yep
there he is Joe Biden vice president the
United States and a shakedown
quid pro quo Joe fire that prosecutor in
six hours I'll give you a billion
dollars you don't fire him I won't give
you a billion dollars why on earth with
a vice president the United States of
America care about a prosecutor in
Ukraine the answer is obvious his son
was being investigated even the New York
Times warned Biden his son was being
investigated by that prosecutor by the
way Democrats
we found your quid pro quo quid pro quo
Joe a shakedown with taxpayer dollars
and by the way in spite of what Joe
Biden just said a serious potential
violation of multiple laws our own Gregg
Jarrett laid it all out look at your
screen 15 USC 78 it is illegal for a
u.s. person to coerce or influence
through bribery a billion dollars or
storsch in a foreign nation into taking
action oh yeah they took action fire the
prosecutor that might financially
benefit the person his family hunter or
business that's just the tip of the
iceberg 18 USC 201 C whoever gives
offers a billion dollars or promises
anything of value to a public official
to influence an official act part of the
prosecutor is guilty of bribery Wow
these are real laws 18 USC 201 B giving
offering promising a billion dollars
anything of value to a public official
in exchange for official act fire the
prosecutor 18 USC 1951 a threat to a
foreign official in order to obtain but
we won't give you the billion dollars in
order to obtain official benefit
affecting interstate or foreign commerce
could constitute extortion Biden
leverage 1 billion US tax dollars that's
right demanded a farm prosecutor get
fired fire him
you get the billion quid let me do this
slowly for the mob and the media quid
pro quo fire him you get a billion don't
fire him you don't get a billion and son
of a B they fired the prosecutor who we
now know Biden knew was investigating
his own son at the very same time the
company was a vocal hunter Biden's name
all over the Obama State Department what
were they wanting political favors make
these investigations go away is this how
corruption the swamp works isn't it when
their media mob friends lie they say no
evidence of any wrongdoing that's what
the mob says no out or anything
wrongdoing what if this was Vice
President Trump and Don jr. we're really
supposed to accept that this is business
as usual
this is ok nothing here nothing to no
evidence it's a conspiracy theory forget
the law
forget the conflict of interest forget
the hunter Biden got rich off the backs
of US taxpayers and despite all these
documents all this evidence all this
stench and stink in the swamp of
corruption all over Washington DC
not a single whistleblower came
word here no outrage from the mob and
the media no they're too busy making up
excuses they never make for anybody with
the last name Trump Biden was totally
protected just like Hillary was totally
protected
but when Trump upheld his sworn duty
read the transcript enforcing the laws
election interference and asking the
newly elected president of Ukraine to
cooperate with the investigation into
2016 election interference and also
later mentioning Vice President Biden's
misconduct in the country while the
swamp erupts this is outrageous I can't
believe this is happening
and unlike Biden there was no quid pro
quo with Trump no conflict of interest
no crimes of misconduct they got the
money not didn't they didn't do anything
read the transcript totally available
online by the way the president released
the entire thing what other people say
and feel about the transcript oh we are
releasing what so-and-so thinks of the
transcript this is meaningless oh my god
somebody said it's they think it's bad
meaningless read the transcript the
president was faithfully executing the
laws of the land I thought liberals
cared about foreign election
interference look at this corruption
look at what we've now discovered burry
Spaulding's they wanted favor from the
Obama State Department existed on so
many levels
and if releasing transcripts of the new
norm Republicans tonight need to begin
demanding that the release of all
transcripts of Vice President Biden with
any Ukrainian official in this period of
time as a matter of fact stoop for the
whole time he was vice president release
all the transcripts of the vice
president then Biden and China and in
any other country that was paying his
zero experience son of fortune millions
of dollars no other Americans getting
that deal and let's release while we're
at it all transcripts of them President
Obama with Vladimir Putin and any other
Russian leader after he had more
flexibility after his re-election and
while we're at it let's release any and
all transcripts of them President Obama
with any of the leaders of Iran
and the discussions that led up to the
stupidity and the idiocy of giving the
mullahs in Iran the chant death to
America and Israel 150 billion in cash
and other currency why would you ever do
that Republicans need to know and to
demand those transcripts now be released
media needs to ask Joe and Obama hey you
guys give us permission to look at those
transcripts I have a funny feeling
they're not going to want those
transcripts released now by the way
Republicans must demand subpoenas while
they're at it four very important
witnesses we're going to start with the
non whistleblower whistleblower in other
words the hearsay whistleblower the BFF
of the compromised coward and yeah the
congenital liar Adam Schiff and
apparently his staff also apparently
friends of Biden he wasn't on the call
as information was hearsay third hand
material Republicans must demand this
non whistleblower go under oath what was
the contact with chef's office what was
a relationship with Biden who was the
person that gave you this third hand
information and let's be clear the
whistleblower statute does not guarantee
anonymity does protect against
retribution retaliation they must also
demand that hunter and Joe Biden that
they be put under oath that they be
subpoenaed let's not forget the corrupt
compromise congenital liar Adam Schiff
he is now a fact witness in this case
let's put him under oath Schiff in fact
his office what did what advice did they
offer the non whistleblower
whistleblower from the very beginning he
can't bring the whistleblower in because
the whistleblower will be asked
questions about him this is a setup
it's all been conjured again by deep
state unelected bureaucrats that are
just obsessed with impeaching Trump
because they can't beat him and carrying
out the most corrupt person in
Washington sole thing is being carried
out by the biggest congenital liar this
is a clown show a three-ring circus that
guy's been lying for three years